in May of 2011 Microsoft announced that
they would be buying Skype for 8.5
billion dollars in cash from the very
beginning it seemed like Microsoft had
overpaid for Skype just two years before
this Skype had been sold for a third of
this price coming in at 2.75 billion
dollars there was no way that skype's
value had it tripled Within These 24
months especially given the 2008
financial recession Microsoft very much
knew this but if they wanted to get
Skype this was the price they had to pay
it because two other Giants Google and
Facebook were also interested in
acquiring Skype it appears that
Microsoft hadn't won the bidding wars
but now it was time for the actual hard
stuff they needed to ensure that this
overpriced purchase would actually be
worth it over the long term
unfortunately by all accounts they would
miserably fail at doing this public
distaste for Skype simply grew year
after year and people were simply
waiting for a viable alternative to pop
up for gamers this turned out to be
Discord for everyday people this turned
out to be FaceTime and WhatsApp and for
schools and institutions this turned out
to be Zoom things actually got so bad
that Microsoft themselves shut down
Skype for business in the middle of 2021
hearing all this you would think that
Skype was a massive failure and it
technically Skype itself was indeed a
failure but what if I told you that
Skype as an investment was actually a
massive a win for Microsoft you see it
just as Skype started hitting its
breaking point in the late 2010s
Microsoft went out and iterated on Skype
themselves and created a new solution
Microsoft teams if you're a tech worker
you're probably extremely familiar with
the Microsoft teams and this sound
probably gives you nightmares if you're
not familiar with teams this is
basically the business equivalent of
this sound anyway according to Microsoft
softer themselves teams is their fastest
growing business app of all time and
let's not forget Microsoft is also the
creators of office in the Outlook so
this is truly an achievement between
March and June of 2020 teams actually
grew faster than Zuma growing a whopping
at 894 percent and today teams has a
total of 270 million users which isn't
not that far behind a zoom's 300 million
users not to mention it teams users are
way more profitable given that they're
more likely to be business users in 2020
for example Zoom pulled in just over 4
billion dollars while teams actually
pulled in nearly 7 billion dollars yet
all the media ever talks about is a zoom
so here's the rise and fall of Skype and
its insane Resurrection as teams
foreign
taking a look back the story of Skype
dates back to 2003 to two Scandinavian
men named Nicholas zenstroma and the
genus freeze the idea was to
substantially reduce the cost of a long
distance phone calls if you have family
in other countries it you're probably
well aware of just how expensive this is
and this is still the case to this day
but nowadays your first instinct
wouldn't be to hop on Skype it would
probably be to use FaceTime or Whatsapp
back in the early 2000s though these
options didn't even exist so you either
had to pay ATT and arm and a leg or you
had to put up with MSN Messenger skype's
Founders were acutely aware of the
situation and that they felt that the
industry was just asking for disruption
so like any good entrepreneurs they got
to work they would partner with some
Estonian developers and that they would
create a minimal viable product by the
end of the year and they would call it
Skype which stands for Skype
peer-to-peer Skype was a massive hit
almost instantaneously
there was clearly a bunch of cooped of
demand that was just waiting for a
better solution and Skype was exactly
that the founders built on the success
by expanding into traditional phone
calls as well with the launch of Skype
out skypeout allowed users to directly
call a landline or mobile phone from
their computers this probably doesn't
sound like a big deal today but back in
2005 it this was insane because not
everyone even had computers this meant
that you could leverage Skype even if
only one person had access to a computer
and the best part was that it costed it
a mere two cents per minute for
perspective if you don't have an
international Planet ATT will
shamelessly charge you 2.71 cents per
minute and that's in 2022 who knows how
much ATT charged in 2005. anyway the
cost and convenience of Skype made it a
no-brainer within 18 months of launching
Skype would cross 23 million registered
users and within two years they would
cause a 100 million downloads Skype was
still very much just a startup but
bigger corporations were already
interested in acquiring the business and
we weren't talking about tens of
millions or even hundreds of millions we
were talking about billions 2.6 billion
from eBay to be exact kaipe had gone
from zero to 2.6 billion in a matter of
two and a half years not a bad day's
work but Skype was still just getting
started at the end of 2005 Skype would
launch video calling and in mid-2006
they would launch support for massive
calls with up to 100 people by the end
of 2007 Skype would reach 220 million
registered users and by all accounts
they were crushing it but despite all
this growth eBay was finding it more and
more difficult to keep up with Skype
there was virtually no Synergy between
the two companies so it was basically
like running two different businesses
soon enough eBay just wanted out so they
would sell Skype to the first buyer they
could find for a terrible evaluation of
2.75 billion these buyers would simply
turn around and flip Skype to Microsoft
a few years later for 8.6 billion
dollars in Cold Hard Cash and that
brings us into the Microsoft era
Microsoft bought the top that's simply
the truth and there's no way around it
to make things worse not only did they
buy the top but they overpaid it at the
top due to the bidding war but wait a
minute hold up what happened wasn't
Skype growing at an insane Pace with no
end in sight well unfortunately the
reality was that there was an end inside
and the reasoning was obvious the number
one selling factor of Skype was its
functionality people didn't use it
because it had a cool UI or great
integration and Synergy or any of that
people used it simply because it solved
a problem but as we moved into the 2010s
there were several services that could
solve the same problem but these other
services also came with a bunch of extra
bells and whistles WhatsApp for example
actually offered an enjoyable mobile
experience unlike Skype meanwhile Google
Hangouts and Apple Facetime were able to
tap into the massive networks of Gmail
and iPhone users and for most people
switching to the Services was a
no-brainer why settle for just a
functionality when you could opt for
functionality and a great user
experience this isn't to say that Skype
stopped growing per se in fact in terms
of pure numbers they continued their
exponential growth into the billions of
users the problem though was that these
weren't happy users these were users
that were becoming increasingly
frustrated and the only reason they use
Skype was because everyone around them
was using it it was popular because it
was already popular likely the two
biggest complaints about Skype were that
the UI sucked and the service itself was
not as reliable as competitors the first
point is not that surprising I mean
we're talking about Microsoft here
despite their enormous size they've
never been able to get mobile right I
mean just think about the Windows phone
which lost them at 8 billion dollars the
problem was that Microsoft was always
trying to import a computer-based
experience onto a mobile device which
simply didn't translate well meanwhile
their competitors were reimagining how
every task could be done on a phone from
scratch and the competitors destroyed
Microsoft every time as for the
reliability problem this wasn't exactly
Microsoft's fault but they weren't able
to fix it either the reason that Skype
was so unreliable was because it was a
peer-to-peer service the reliability of
a peer-to-peer connection was simply
uncomparable to a server-based
connection backed by a 13 billion dollar
data center Microsoft tried to address
this by moving Skype to the cloud but
this move was always kind of botched not
to mention it this move also kind of
backfired as it made people think that
Microsoft was trying to track your data
and if you were gonna let Microsoft
collect your data you might as well let
Google and Facebook collect your data at
least you'll have a good UI there if you
want some quantitative data regarding
just how much people hated Skype well in
June of 2017 the average App Store
rating for Skype dropped from three
point 5 stars to 1.5 Stars yeah it
wasn't that bad but at the same time no
one cared enough to switch either until
the pandemic people figured that if they
were going to use video conferencing on
a regular basis they had to find a
better solution in it and the answer was
zoom and this pretty much sealed the
fate of Skype
during all of this Microsoft was by no
means oblivious to what was happening
they were literally waiting to get
destroyed in the consumer Market but at
the same time eh Microsoft oddly didn't
mind you see it the entire company was
moving away from consumer products I
mean they've literally made windows and
office free for consumers the reason for
this is that Microsoft is no longer a
consumer business the majority of the
revenue actually comes from a B2B
revenue for things like Cloud
infrastructure servers databases and the
licensing with that being said Skype no
longer fit inside their wheelhouse
something that did fit thougha was a
business video conferencing Microsoft
already had strong relationships with
virtually every company in the world
given that basically every company has
to license Windows Office and Outlook so
why not sell them another solution that
seamlessly integrates with these
products and that this led to the launch
of Skype for business in 2015. Microsoft
quickly realized though that the Skype
of branding wasn't doing them any favors
so they would embark on a complete
rebranding which led to the launch of
Microsoft teams in 2017. it wasn't all
sunshines and rainbows though as most
businesses already had established video
conferencing systems from Cisco Cisco
WebEx was nothing to brag about but it
got the job done and accompanies it
didn't see a reason to switch As a
result adoption of teams was lackluster
to say the least by the end of 2017
teams only handed 2 million users and
even by the end of 2018 teams only had 8
million users 2019 was a much better
year for teams as they finally got into
the tens of millions of users but the
Breakthrough obviously didn't come till
2020. as we all know 2020 forced
everyone to reevaluate their video
conferencing Solutions and the choice
was pretty clear why WebEx was an
obvious no if you're not familiar with
WebEx into basically the business
equivalent of Skype this left companies
with two options Zoom or teams both
products offered leading conferencing
Solutions but teams had a slight leg up
on Zoom which was integration with the
Microsoft's other products for companies
that already relied on Microsoft
products this Synergy was simply too
good to pass on and I think you can
guess what happened next
today teams doesn't receive all that
much attention just like Microsoft
themselves but don't let this fool you
teams is the real king of a video
conferencing for most people using Zoom
was an unfortunate temporary reality and
they ditch Zoom it as soon as they could
this isn't very much reflected in zoom's
stock graph for most companies however
using teams is a permanent solution and
given that companies are pretty hesitant
on switching services they're probably
locked in for several years if not
decades so Microsoft's 8.5 billion
acquisition has turned into 6.8 billion
dollars in Revenue every single year and
that that was as of 2020 when teams had
75 million users since then their user
account has grown nearly four-folded to
270 million so teams Revenue today is
definitely above 10 billion dollars and
probably closer to 20 billion dollars
and if you're still not convinced about
team success just listen to this last
quarter Microsoft made a 5.3 billion
dollars from Windows their most
well-known product if we annualized this
we get about 21.2 billion dollars per
year in other words team's revenue is
literally comparable to that of Windows
and it's probably just a matter of time
until teams overtakes Windows altogether
we should also note that the sector that
teams is part of is already at 11.5
billion dollars per quarter which is
twice a windows so who knows maybe it
teams has already overtaken windows and
that's why Skype was likely Microsoft's
best acquisition of all time Skype
itself didn't work out all that well but
it gave rise to the Behemoth that is
teams did you hate Skype comment that
down below also drop a like if you would
like to see more business case studies
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggest for your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions at logically answered but
until then I'm Hari it and I'll see you
guys on the next one